[Music]
it's been called the land that God had
forsaken long considered one of the
harshest environments on earth and for
good reason
summertime we start to hit a hundred
usually in mid-april and usually don't
continue with that through mid-october
in the middle of July June July and
August 120 easily Allen Van Valkenburg
knows he's been a park ranger in Death
Valley for over a decade
the hottest I felt was 129 the day a hit
129 I went out sat in the in the shaded
area that was outside just to kind of
think about what it felt like and there
was a slight breeze blowing and I you
know you'd think a slight breeze would
cool you down because it was in the
shade that side of me
it felt if I thought I was gonna come
away being Redfern the vast expanses of
sand and rock are seemingly devoid like
in the valleys most hostile spot the
miles and miles of salt flats are
completely parched on average the valley
gets less than two inches of rain each
year some years they don't get any at
all in this extreme desolate landscape
life is often hidden of course there are
common creatures bighorn sheep that live
up in the mountains coyotes snakes
spiders and other desert denizens they
all have one thing in common the ability
to sniff out water in a place that looks
bone-dry
there is water I mean surrounding the
hills and canyons of this park there are
over 500 different small seeps and
springs we are at the largest collection
of springs Ranger Charlie Callahan knows
that where there's water there's life
and in Death Valley there's more water
than meets the eye it's that ability for
both fauna and flora to survive here
that Callie and find so remarkable there
it's amazing there's over a thousand
different species of plants found in
Death Valley there there's several dozen
of them that are endemic that are found
nowhere else in the world and although
most of Death Valley looks exactly as it
did thousands of years ago the seeming
desolation can't be full of surprises